hi everyone I'm Carol D and these are my
favorite snacks
[Music]
yeah that was tacos oh my God those
Cycles I think I am a spicy girl in all
the ways
and for sure with the snacks I love
spicy things so these are like kind of
chips little chips I think it's made
with corn this is amazing like you can
just eat one because it's
incredible
here listen to this
when I'm on tour I'm all the time
looking for Colombian food because I am
very Colombian I am amazing girl so for
me it's hard to go everywhere like all
the time and not eat my Colombian food
these chips were the ones like I used to
eat the most when I was in school when I
went to it like a snack I ate like big
things but this is one of the few uh
little snacks that I keep like eating
since I was in school
oh my God hmm
a hot dog we call it
for sure if you want to make me happy uh
in our first date just take me to eat
like a hot dog or a pizza and I'm gonna
be super super happy about it like we in
Colombia I think we do it a little
different from other parts of the world
for example in New York I see you just
put the bread and the sausage and just
like ketchup or something like that but
for us aperito a hot dog can have like
everything so you can put bacon eggs
salad potato chips you can put like
whatever you want in a hot dog and this
is the way we eat it so now I have in my
hands
[Music]
palito de queso mozzarella sticks this
is a dream
if you go to Colombia you're gonna buy
this like in every corner you're gonna
find a place like little bakeries where
they do this this compete a lot with
empanadas I know I didn't ask for
empanadas right but between this the
technitos
colombianas my God I can die and I can
live with this my whole life
and glueless
when I open this that's gonna smell a
lot
oh patakones okay these are patacones in
other places you're gonna find them as
tostones and I here I think it's just
fried plantain I don't know you have to
try it with ogaw ogao is the name of a
sauce and you put it on this with a lot
of salt and a little bit of avocado and
normally people do this with bananas and
plantains but for me green green
plantain is really green it tastes even
better just hear this
oh
[Music]
glad okay see the name of this is choco
Ramo this is like little piece of
vanilla cake covered with chocolate no I
need to open it because I need to show
it to you it's a little piece of cake
made by moms you know mom's food is
delicious so I think these are moms
doing these cakes
this is very very popular in Colombia if
you go to Colombia and then you're
coming back and you are in the airport
and you want to buy like souvenirs or
things for sure you're gonna find this
because this is very representative of
our culture
foreign
I don't know what to say speechless
is that candy
very sweet and it has inside like uh
bubble gum so you have to just
liquid and a lot and then you're gonna
find like the bubble gum inside this
this is
Colombian snack with it this everywhere
for everything even when you go to
parties and disco you're gonna find
girls just dancing and have the boom
boom boom normal that's super normal and
this remember me a lot to my childhood
because we're used to do a lot of thing
just to get one boom boom boom
it doesn't have anything else it's just
chocolate but the tastes it's really
different and we used to share it when I
was in school if you have one you need
to share it like the the tradition is
you share like a little piece and
something very cool about these
chocolates inside you're gonna find like
a picture of something traditional for
our country from Colombia and in the
back of the thing you're gonna find like
the explanation of what what are you
seeing I get like a traditional dance El
horopo very well chloric I don't know if
it's the word but it's something that
represents a lot
super cocoa this is very representative
of our country I know in like there are
a lot of places where they have Cocos
coconut this candy has something special
on it I don't really know the
ingredients but I know it has a secret
so when you taste it it's full of
coconut inside little little pieces of
coconut inside is delicious amazing very
Colombian
but you really did the homework that
those over the snacks are the most
representative of my country
la nozita
but this is a new one my God
nozita this is very Colombian but I just
found out something in this new package
that they have a new flavor that I
didn't know and it was like that when I
was in school it was just like the
chocolate and the white chocolate but
now I think it's like a strawberry
chocolate this is used to it with a
little here
they change it too it's like a little
spoon
uh it's amazing
[Music]
so thank you so much everybody for being
here with me
Colombiano Historia I love you so much
and remember to listen to my new album
[Music]